there is agreement on a joint European
position on the EU counterterrorism
directive we have today adopted the
directive of the european parliament and
of the council on the use of passenger
name records being our data for the
prevention detection investigation and
prosecution of terrorist offences and
serious crime agreement was also reached
on the data protection package and
council conclusions have been adopted to
combat human trafficking today we set
out our ambitious and ambitions and
intentions to set meaningful steps in
the area of information exchange to
combat terrorism illegal or irregular
migration and cross-border crime we have
debated the systemic feeding and
consistent use of European and
international databases this is a follow
up on the ministerial statement of the
24th of march in the aftermath of the
horrendous Brussels attacks it is vital
to share our information so we can
enable real-time analysis and
cross-border operational actions let me
start with turkey and turkey EU
agreements a month ago we concluded
disagreement so now it's time to deliver
on the agreement and we need to do it
fast and this means that we all as
member sites have to assist Greece in
processing asylum requests and sending
migrants back to Turkey and that we all
have to resettle Syrian refugees from
Turkey under the one on one system today
more pledges came forward and that's
good news and we have decided to work in
a plant matter on a credible number of
resettlement from Turkey we agreed that
we should negotiate with the European
Parliament as quickly as possible but
also start preparations for
implementation European beauregard
should take off as soon as possible and
it's our preference that it will be
already this summer the reform of the
common European asylum system is one of
the main issues we are now focusing on
today's discussion was a first exchange
of views with the ministers and I'm
happy to hear that we all want to
improve the system in any case not just
only w but the entire common European
asylum system I also today debrief
ministers on the car
state of play in implementing the
eu-turkey agreement the number of
arrivals at sea has decreased the first
returns to turn to turkey took place as
well as the first resettlements from
turkey to european union under the
one-to-one scheme our attention goes to
addressing the humanitarian situation on
the ground English and bearing in mind
the needs of the most vulnerable this is
precisely why we cannot forget about
relocation and I have reminded ministers
today very firmly about this but I have
also underlined three ministers that it
is essential for the European Union
countries to step up efforts and
resettle Syrian refugees under the
one-to-one scheme rapidly the irregular
migratory corridors can only end if
people offered a channel and legal
alternative